okay guess I need to speak up a bit more
we're gonna wait a couple more minutes
because they're still folks signing in
but if you want already you can get
started signing up while not signing up
sorry connecting to the Wi-Fi so down
here we have the LaSalle J s con
the password is just lower case
altogether j s conf Asia and then you
can already check out we have a little
sort of boilerplate repo you can have a
look at that's just that bitly stripe J
s conf
so maybe just have a look at that to see
that the internet and everything is
working you know updates to the latest
stable node version things like that and
then we'll we'll kick off in a in a
couple minutes
Cheers
at my work it's not money
oh yeah something else you can do is you
can if you don't know each other sitting
you know on your group tables you can
just introduce yourself to each other
cool
we don't are we night
I think let's kick off into them
good
good in general less conferences oh it's
the recording mic so you might have to
be careful yeah yeah yeah
we got some more chairs up here does
everyone have a chair there's some free
space over here in the front
don't worry I'll try not to no spits
cool
oh I haven't installed my update screen
cool should we kick off
[Music]
change what oh it's well it's not gonna
change it's literally just one slice but
then it's gonna change to the screen
okay
but maybe I can do like introductions
and stuff yeah I'm on miramos yes
should i unblock Reebok
does anyone know what that is is that
the metro oh oh yes national day when is
when is that Singh Singapore any
Singaporeans sorry August 8th okay
cool should I try to unblock replac or
okay I think it's ten past we're gonna
kick off hello everyone whoo can you
hear me in the back is that is that okay
perfect
yeah as you can probably see I'm not
Paul a bit of wrong advertisement there
on the door but I actually live in
Paul's home country so I live in
Amsterdam in the Netherlands the team
here imported me so to speak because we
actually all of our engineering team in
in the Singapore office is currently in
Europe so they they are doing an
off-site it's a bit of bad timing but I
got lucky so I I got to come out here
and work with you guys which is really
cool so my name is Thor it's actually
tossed in which means Thor stone but no
one can remember that so Thor yeah I'm
I'm a integration engineer and developer
advocate at stripe I generally work with
our users in northern Europe very
different climate over there speak
colder but yeah generally help them
build more sort of complex marketplace
integration so money goes in money goes
out yeah that's a marketplace we have
some other stripes here so we have Paul
whom you've met at the talk earlier we
have Daniel and Chris so they're gonna
be around to you know help you out if
there are any issues any questions yes
and Shane way in the back of course
sorry
so if you have any questions we're all
wearing striped tee shirts so you can
just point at us or you know just kind
of raise your hand we're going to be
we're going to be running around
Wi-Fi so we have the LaSalle J s Khan
fly fi down here we're gonna need that
because we're going to need to
communicate with the stripe API and then
the password is J s conf Asia just
lowercase and we have sort of a
boilerplate repo that I'm just going to
run you through in a second there which
you can access by going to bitly slash
stripe J s conf cool did everyone have a
good lunch
are you a bit tired now or no good okay
so we can we can jump in on the
recording there are you getting a signal
August fantastic cool so if you go to
bitly Wow
strike J s conf you're going to get to
this repo here so we've we've set
together to set up this the spoiler
plate repo here what we want to do is
kind of take you through a couple
different integration approaches with
stripe so we're gonna kick off in the
beginning with stripe check out actually
can I get a quick show of hands who here
has integrated stripe before okay
some folks if you've done so have you
integrated the new check out already
no okay so we're gonna we're going to
look at a new version of check out and
that is actually something we can
implement there's a client only version
with check out where for example you can
implement payments into aesthetic site
with gets before example yeah that's
that's actually something that that we
can do with the client only checkout so
in that case we don't need a server but
we're gonna look also add at the
checkout session peace with which then
needs a server and from there we're
gonna move on to a more customized
checkout using drop in UI components
called stripe elements Chris is gonna
take you through that and then lastly we
want to look at the payment request API
as well as Apple pay on the web and
Google pay using the payment request API
cool in terms of the repo here you can
see we have two different modes so we
have a vanilla chase mode and we have a
react motion now if you're not very
familiar with react
I think choose maybe the vanilla J's
mode or if you have an existing project
that you want to add payments to you
know that that you have on your machine
locally or somewhere you can do that of
course as well otherwise feel free to
use the repository for react you know if
you're familiar with reacts you can use
the stripe react elements library that
is linked also here in the docs the
react stripe elements so if you're
familiar with react you know you use the
react mode lastly we have some
documentation here we're going to we're
going to jump into that before we do
that you can use this repo if you're
using this repo
you can simply clone it and run it
locally we have different NPM scripts
set up to run the vanilla mode as well
as the react note we've implemented
end Rock does anyone know what end rock
is cool who doesn't know what Angra is
okay everyone's sort of awake so and
Rock actually allows us to have a tunnel
from our localhost to the web and
specifically that is an easy way for us
to test web hooks if we have the server
running locally on our machine so we're
actually going to look at web hooks in a
bit so these are HTTP requests where
information from stripe that are sent to
your server and using em cropped we can
tunnel those requests to our localhost
alternatively you know I've seen glitch
being used quite lot here at Jas con so
that's something you can do as well in
clich if you open your new project you
can simply paste in the URL so here if
you go into HTTP mode you can paste in
the the URL and set up the project on
glitch with that if you if you want to
do that then you don't have to use n
grok because it's actually available on
the internet maybe quick question does
who does have a UNIX based OS so
something like Mac OS or Linux ok good
amount anyone who has a window space
system ok you're probably used to
everything being a bit more difficult
but that's ok
alternatively you know do feel free to
use glitch if you know the setup doesn't
work cool from that
let's actually jump into the docs
let's open that and in you tap
so the new striped checkout if you've
known if you work with stripe checkout
before there was actually a modal pop-up
on your site that was basically an
iframe that's injected to securely
submit the card details in the payment
details to stripe we would then exchange
these details to a token that can only
be used with your secret key and then
using that token you can charge the
details
now with the new stripe checkout it's
actually even easier than that so it's a
stripe hosted checkout experience and
what you actually do is you redirect off
to the stripe checkout page using the
stripe j/s web SDK so we can quickly
look at how this works so here if you go
into the checkout Doc's you can click on
preview check out we can see we go off
to a stripe hosted checkout page you can
specify the product images that should
be shown if you have a cart that has
more items you can you can have multiple
items that are shown on that page and
you can customize that here you can see
stripe press we have a little logo up
there
so that is a very easy way to get
started and as I mentioned it offers a
client client only checkout version that
allows us to actually use checkout
without a server component now what I
can do is I send me an email if you if
you want to I can use here this is
running in test mode I can use our test
cart details if you look in into the
repo we have a testing section where we
also link to all the different test
cards that you can use here I'm just
using the default test card for two for
two actually fun facts we a while ago we
bought that specific bin space so no one
can actually issue a credit card with
for two for two
wanted to make sure that doesn't happen
well no one except us can do that so we
actually owned the bin space and we can
now use this test card and we made a
successful payment and then upon a
successful payment we get returned back
to our success URL and we can see here
we've completed a successful purchase
cool now in order to do the client only
integration so that's something that we
want to do first we actually do need a
striper couch so if you don't have a
test stripe test account yet here in the
getting started steps you can just click
on the link open a new test account
we're just gonna
yeah so actually just follow along with
me do do that now open open a quick test
account GS conf
he's implementing that I just wanted to
let you know that this current charges
for anything for you it actually is
simply peasant now don't click the
activate button up in the corner and you
don't have to put any sort of like
details or anything this is just a lot
of you to get started
and here we're seeing the fun effects
off our security measures because you're
all signing up at the moment and you're
all on the same network we're thinking
this is some fun card cash
cashing going on here testing so does
anyone else get that error message at
the moment no everyone got their stripe
account then I might just actually use
the one I have yeah so this is it this
is a fun thing because we're probably
all on the same IP address on the
network if anyone else runs into that
let me know
just gonna try again
not a roll boss trust me
there we are fantastic so what we want
to select is solutions for developers
and then what we can do here what can we
do you can get our test API keys
business information so you don't need
to activate the account this is just a
test account now running in test mode
what we can do now is we can quickly
look into the settings maybe look at the
checkout settings here and I think we
actually need to enable the client
integration so if we want to use that
maybe quickly check that now your
popular seed you generate checkout pages
yes we want that allow
so in in test mode we can provide any
you know we can call the redirect to
stripe checkout from any domain like
including localhost but in live mode we
actually need you to register the domain
because there's no server component for
you to actually validate that the
checkout session because we're creating
the checkout session client sites we
actually verify that it is created on
the client from your domain in life mode
don't worry about that in test mode
cool yeah if anyone has problems at any
point just raise your hand we have some
folks flying around who will life debug
with you okay and then we create our
first product so because with the client
only integration we don't have a server
component we actually need stripe to be
aware of what you're selling as you
probably know we can't trust the front
end we can't really trust any
information that is coming from the
front end unfortunately someone might
have tempered with that even just the
person you know in the in the dev
console and the developer tools might
have changed the amount so we we
actually need to tell stripe this is the
product we want to sell this is the
amount so we call that products and SKUs
so stock keeping unit that's askew so
let's quickly ask at a test product I'm
just going to select the one-time
purchase here you can also create plans
for subscriptions for recurring payments
but what I'm just going to do is you
probably have seen all the issues of
increment we have there in the back
which is a magazine that we publish
about kind of different engineering
topics and scaling engineering
organizations we probably want Singapore
dollars here
now I'm not sorry I'm not gonna how do I
get out of this RS I'm not gonna upload
an image but I'm just gonna say ten
Singapore dollars create Dutch
and now we can see here we have a
product ID and we have a SKU ID does
everyone have their product and SKU
awesome so SKU stands for stock keeping
unit so if you have a product for
example jas kana t-shirt an SKU is the
actual version or the variant off that
t-shirt so for example the size the
color and you know the printing style
so those three combinations make up one
unique SKU correct yeah it's sort of a
general inventory if you're selling
physical goods
it actually makes more sense if you're
selling digital goods really isn't that
important what you know the SKU is
necessarily cool and now what we can
actually do here is we can click use
with a checkout and you can fill in your
success URL and your cancer URL here
which is going to refer to you know for
example localhost URLs but we're going
to copy and paste that into into our
code I just want to quickly walk you
through what happens very briefly so
here we load the stripe j/s javascript
library we then have a button the button
actually has a roll link just in terms
of you know screen readers for example
to make sure we we know that this is
actually gonna link us to a different
page
we can specify an error message here and
then we can quickly look at the script
so we initialize the stripe client
library the stripe JavaScript library
with our publishable key so that is
gonna identify okay this is creating a
checkout session for my stripe account
and for example it's going to validate
the the domain the origin domain in life
note that you've registered we then here
have a click listener for our button if
you look into the boiler place we
actually have a button in there that you
can use and then we're simply calling
stripe redirect to check out and we
specify a list of views here we have
only our single SKU we can specify the
quantity and then our success our cancel
URLs and as you can see here that is a
promise so the reason for the promise is
here there is an API request happening
to stripe and we're waiting for the
results to come back now what could the
results be anyone have an idea here
looking looking at this can you see that
not at this point yet so we were just at
the point where we want to redirect off
to the strai poster checkout page and so
the reason that is implemented as a
promise is we need to validate that the
SKU ID that was provided actually
belongs to your account that everything
is valid and if everything was well at
what we returned is basically the
checkout session with a redirect URL to
the stripe hosted checkout but if there
is an error we want to actually catch
that error on our page and react to it
so if there's no error what actually
happens is we're going to redirect off
to the stripe checkout but if there's an
error we can we can react to it cool and
I think this is the point where I'm
going to let you go off to the races and
implement that yourself if you're very
quick with the client only checkout it's
mainly copy and paste here and if you
run into any issues do do just raise
your hand but if you're quick you can go
back here to the check out in
documentation and you can look at the
server integration piece where you can
then actually you don't need to register
the products with stripe anymore because
you're doing all of that on your server
and then you can actually provide a list
of line items and you can have a look at
that cool
everyone happy to sort of race off and
take some test money awesome yes a
question
yeah so here the here yeah so stripe to
redirect to check out that function
actually returns a promise
so can you can use s Inc aways
oh if the browser's too old is that what
you mean so the browser doesn't support
promises it's a good question what
happens in that case does anyone know
yeah we so we we just we we ship sort of
a polyfill I guess yeah
yeah if you have more questions just ask
Paul brilliant okay cool
then yeah I'll let you go off you know
let's let's see what you what are you
selling and if you have questions please
raise your hands
awesome happy hacking
you guys ready to learn a little bit
about stripe elements thank you
so I want to talk a little bit about how
you would embed a credit card form into
your own own website and build a check
out form
so now you've implemented how's everyone
doing on implementing check out
everyone's kind of got that working
feeling good about it so now if you
wanted to build a check out form into
your website closer all right there we
go you can use stripe elements for that
and stripe elements allows your website
to be PCI compliant because it's hosted
on stripe servers and it's actually
embedded in an iframe so what does this
look like for code if you go to the Jas
workshop repository we have a link for
stripe Jas and elements as well as react
stripe elements and then here you can
see I'm going to try to live code a
little bit of this a pile would work so
you can get an example of what this
looks like and see that it will tokenize
cards this form is hosted all on stripe
and when you submit the payment here on
the site then it gets you a successful
token and what you can do with that
token is go to charge your users and so
basically we just want to get stripe
elements set up so that you can start
collecting those tokens and charging
your users so it gets started stripe
elements allows you to put in a div to
your page and tag it with a card element
ID so using the vanilla workshop that we
already have set up you can copy and
paste this form right into your website
and as a part of this the form action
chart goes to forward slash charge
bigger
oh it's really that's really dim
definitely harder to see
can everyone see that
the light background I don't know how to
do that in real-time what do I get where
do I go
just do it he'll still do right oh it's
so much better alright so when you poke
when you post this in it's actually
gonna add a forum to your site so we can
go look at the site and notice that we
now have a credit and debit card form at
a submit payment button that goes to
forward slash charge so once you once
you have that set up you just need a
little bit of CSS to give us some
styling so you can target that stripe
element that we put in there and using
this page and get started so you copy
and paste this in to your style dot CSS
that we already have set up and then
let's go check what that looks like it's
now maybe we have all right so that
style is going to come in as soon as you
embed the form from stripe so using a
little JavaScript this is kind of the
key the core component of implementing
elements into your site you're gonna
pass in styling into stripe because this
is an iframe that's hosted on stripe
servers and you need to tell stripe what
you want this to look like what stripe
is going to give back to you and hosting
this iframe and then as part of that
you're going to create a card element if
you want to take payments of other types
then you can go and look for these
different payment types on the side here
after after this paul is going to go
over how to do payment request buttons
which gives you Apple pay support so
taking this JavaScript and pasting it in
to our index touch a s and commenting
out also I'm using the vanilla J's just
for this quick code demo only just cuz
it's easier to get everything started in
it so hopefully if I've done everything
right you'll now get an iframe that's
actually loading from stripes servers
and you can put in a card and fill it
out and get a token so once I submit
this it's going to submit it to forward
slash charge and that's actually going
to pass you back a token that you can
use to charge users so if you look at
the code that was generated on the
documentation page you'll see that when
the submit happens when the user hits
the submit button there is an event
listener and that actually calls stripe
dot create token and from that we can
print out the results so everyone can
see actually that will refresh so here
this code right here is where you can
get that token to be able to handle the
payment and if you want to change where
the users get sent when they actually
hit that submit button you can change
this form action right here so that's
how to get started on getting stripe
elements onto your page and I didn't do
any sort of styling or customization but
now you can kind of play around with
embedding a form and accept payments
into your site directly
so that's stripe elements and getting
started give you guys some time to
implement that and change the look and
feel on this and let us know if you have
any questions at all
actually any questions that you'd like
me to answer yeah so the same as sorry
the question was is it supposed to
redirect a forward slash charge is that
the expected behavior you can think of
that URL as the same as the success URL
for a new checkout so the same you could
change that the same way that you did
the success for part of the the checkout
any other questions
awesome
just as work call so there's actually so
the whole reason behind you know stripe
elements is to give you PCI compliance
by providing kind of an injecting an
iframe so only the input fields that the
car details are typed into only that
piece is is an iframe and everything
else in your form you can completely
customize and even the stripe element
you can provide a style object to
actually style the input fields that is
hosted by stripe and PCI compliance
means we want to make sure that there is
no card details ever exposed on our
server because if that you know if we
store card details or if we even just
have the card details hit our server
there are certain requirements with that
for handling card details so you know
let's use the iframe and what actually
happens in the background the car
details are securely sent to stripe
using your publishable key we then
encrypt the card details and exchange
them for a token and that token can only
be used with your stripe account now has
anyone here heard of 3d secure yes fun
so actually in Europe there is a there's
a new regulation coming into effects in
September which is called strong
customer authentication and strong
custom authentication will demand that
any payments between European merchants
and European card holders are strongly
authenticated and one mechanism for that
will be 3d secure now even though that
only effects merchants in Europe kind of
looking out into 2020
you know Singapore and Australia Brazil
and other countries around the
are looking at that as well as a way to
tackle online fraud and so what we've
done at stripe is we've built 3d secure
authentication into our client SDKs to
help you to handle that dynamically and
we call it dynamic authentication Oh
so the way this works is first on our
server we create a payment intent and
you can think of the payment intent as
an object to basically track our
customers intent to purchase something
so we create the payment intent by
simply specifying the amount and the
currency that we want to collect so this
is something that we need to do once we
know ok we want to collect 10 Singapore
dollars from our customer we want to
create the payment intent and then the
payment intent itself has a client
secret and so the client secret we need
to sent down to our front end and then
we can use stripe Jas and the elements
that we just used to call handle card
payment do you have that on you in your
client client yes
so using using the payment intent client
secret so the payment intent we create
on our server and then we share the
client secret with our our front-end and
then we can simply call stripe dot
handle card payment so that's part of
stripe Jas and we pass in the client
secret and card here is the reference to
our stripe card element okay so what you
just setup that's where the cardi toads
are and then what we do here with stripe
J s we attach the card details to our
payment intent and at that point we
actually evaluate you know we run our
real-time machine learning based wrists
fraud score detection and depending on
rules you can actually in the stripe
dashboard you can write rules when 3d
secure should be triggered so by default
we evaluate the regulation rules so for
example in September in Europe we will
identify okay this is a European card it
requires to be strongly authenticated so
let's bring up 3d secure and you can see
here in test mode we render a test 3d
secure page where you can then off the
rise or fail the authentication step and
depending on that we then resolve the
promise so stripe dot handle car payment
is a function again that returns a
promise bless you
which then resolves with either a
successful payment intent status or a
failed status depending on whether it
was successful
yes and so to test this actually you can
use a test card that requires 3d secure
authentication we've linked that for you
in the repo as well but so going back
yeah so here the payment and ten stocks
so if you if you pull those up so what
we need to do first now is when our
customer gets to our checkout page we
need to create a payment intent
so either we send an a check request to
our back-end to to create a payment
intent or if you you know render your
page on the server you can just create
that before you actually render out
anything once you've got the payment
intent created you need to then call
stripe J s Handel card payment with the
client secret of your payment intent and
the reference to your stripe element and
that will then dynamically handle
authentication okay everyone fully
confused now good now any questions
about the payment intent yes
correct so the question is does the
promise only resolved when the customer
has authenticated the payment so yes in
the case that authentication is required
the promise will only resolve when
either the customer has successfully
authenticated or they've cancelled the
authentication step for example
yeah what if they just pass in that case
it does timeout depending on your bank
so what is actually shown is the issuer
page from the bank and depending on that
it can timeout that is correct and in
that case if it times out the promise
resolves with an error yeah okay so the
first thing we need to do now is on our
server create a payment intent and from
the repository you can click on in the
documentation section on payment intent
and then follow the steps there okay
cool
yay authentication and again if you have
any questions you know please ask us
awesome thanks
this does it in a very nice way I do so
I do realize that was a maybe a bit fast
so let me actually run through this and
like if you know sort of what you're
doing
feel free to just ignore me and and run
along but yeah let me actually kind of
run through this
so if we use payment and tens the first
thing we need to do and let's go into
the quick start here
and let's not use darknets so we need to
create our payment intent so what we
actually do is on our server now that
that's not the server this is the server
yeah
we see if I can
okay maybe like that a bit smaller
cool yeah our account code references
references and there's color theme I
just picked that likely just to get one
light yes okay call me even bigger how
am I supposed to coat them okay so what
we need is a new route on our back end
and we're actually so I'm going to use
an HX request to create my payment
intent from from the front end so I'm
gonna do a post request here I'm gonna
call it payment intent and then what we
actually want to do is create our
payment and cents actually do I have to
have stripe set up yeah so I have my
require stripe up here if you haven't in
the dot end file add your stripe secret
key so there's an end file in here don't
share that with anyone so not like I'm
doing right now and make sure to set
your secret key from from the stripe
dashboard so you have that in there cool
so we have thoughts and I actually we
can just so the thing is we need to make
sure it's an async function so I'm gonna
use async a ways so make sure here our
function that's executed when the post
request hits as asynchronous and then we
can simply say that we want to create
the payment intent so payment intent
create and I'm just gonna say we want 10
so we need to specify it in the smallest
unit off the currency so with Singapore
dollars is it cents do you call it cents
I guess so ten hundred cents so 10
Singapore dollars here and then actually
what we want to return is let's use
camel case here the payment in tent
yeah
I can't just use dosh
cool oh age sounds good give that save
so now on in the front end
let's use vanilla Jas so we have here
our a sink main function and now we need
to here we have a net conflict
and let's just hear when we look after
we loaded the stripe library let's just
fetch basically creates payment intent
and I never like I can't ever remember
fetch most
you know that was example do we need
that much stuff
[Music]
soon your method first we don't really
take so generally you know when you do
this you you have a cart on your front
end and the card probably has a list of
SKU IDs or item IDs that are in the cart
and then generally you would post that
cart through your back-end on your
back-end you would then check in the
database based on you know the items
that are in the carts this is the amount
that I need to charge with just how did
the hard-coded the amount at the moment
so we're not going to actually send
anything so I think the only thing I
need to do is say that we want to post
so let me just quickly take that space
and French URL and then the options okay
so here we called our route payment
intent and then we say we want method
that's a string gonna be lowercase
doesn't matter maybe do the uppercase
give that safe and what we're actually
doing here so the fetch method returns a
promise and then on that promise we call
we basically turn the results into JSON
and then we want to store the Chaisson
in to say payment intent equals weight
and then maybe for now actually just log
out that payment intent
and what I'd like to do is just log it
out as an object then we can interact
with it nicely in the console now let's
actually start this up
NPM run vanilla
cool you see first we're fetching the
config then we're posting here to our
payment intent can you actually see that
journey to make that bigger but if we go
into the preview here we can now see the
payment intent object that we've created
and here we can see we have a client
secret and the neat thing here is
actually by exposing the client secret
to our client we can now use our
publishable key to create a payment and
we can actually sort of hand everything
up to stripe j/s including the handling
of the authentication requirements by
just handing over that client secret to
the payment that client secret to stripe
j/s and we need our element as well okay
so
does everyone have a way to create their
payment intent yes or should I give you
some time before we continue what do you
think who's got their payment intent
created at this point okay I'll give you
some time to to implement that
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
okay I've I've quickly added the
elements to my pages well and so now I'm
gonna quickly run through bringing our
payment intent together with the card
details using the card element so you
can see here I've got my element in the
page we we got it here within the card
element so that's our reference to to
our card element which then in takes the
card details so now here in payment
intent what we do is when our button is
clicked the the submit payment button we
then call the handle card payment as I
mentioned with the client secret and we
can submit additional billing details
here for example the the cardholder name
so that make copy that
to my smaller
so actually my client secret here I
don't have it on the [ __ ] button but as
you've seen here I have it on the
payment intent that I've fetched wire my
HX post requests so I can say payment
intent Josh client secret so that's my
client secret if you remember here you
can see in the network tab so that's my
payment intent object
and so payment intent so you
secret and then my card element is this
and so because I've already used the
payment intent name let me actually do
the following let's not do structure it
here but let's just call it result and
then what we're going to do is we're
gonna await this so I'm going to wait
for the promise to resolve and then
we're just going to console.log the
results
oh yeah and I didn't actually add
anything to collect the cardholder name
I'm just gonna put in Thor here
Thor is buying everything oh cool
and that should be it so if I go back to
my page so upon load I got my config I
create my payment intent I set up my
element and now I'm going to use the
test card details that require 3d secure
authentication and when I click
pre-order I get an error yes card button
is not defined and see that's what you
get from copying things
oh wait I already have my pre-order
button so I don't actually need this do
I
I just need where is it
yeah so that that event listener is I
already have my event listener here the
only thing I need to make sure now
because I'm using a wait for the handle
card payment promise I need to make this
an async function I'm not actually using
the events cool let's try that again
here we are requires authentication
submits
well you should be a client secret
string so what am i submitted probably
not a strength
[Music]
anyone see what I'm doing wrong no no I
mean this should be globally scopes my
client see her
did I spell it correctly
[Music]
okay three time's the charm
if I still get an airline probably
do you see what I'm doing wrong okay
let's try this
it is undefined fantastic
oh wait am i clicking - quick now I mean
I thought there might be sounds here say
you mean on fetch yeah so we get we're
gonna sort of change now so the payment
intent here is fine I think the problem
is when we set up two Broughton
I think we got something funky going on
yeah so this is
and I mean it's just the just option
things that change should be fun now
you're turning on the survey machine
is a payment until payment oh it is okay
yeah so should a mother finder stammer
oh yeah so that is my faults here I'm
actually returning in objects on my
server I'm returning an object that then
intends the objects so I might actually
just do this so now we should actually
have the right objects did that restart
let's see
okay yeah now cool
so now we've got the client secret we're
evaluating the car T sales we recognize
that we need to perform authentication
so we're going to approve this and then
the error is not defined that is great
because I change the results so we
actually here need to say so result dog
era but we can already see I think a
console logs icon select the results
here so when the promise resolves we
actually get back our payment intent and
we can now see we have an updated status
here that says succeeded so if we go
into the dashboard and we go into
payments
now I need to give those a refresh
[Music]
okay oh I'm using a different account I
just realized
[Music]
which account am i using so in the
dashboard you would then see your
payment once you're using the right
account so actually let me quickly do
the following just gonna update my API
keys in the and file the thing is if you
update your API keys indeed and file you
actually need to restart the server
manually so here in the durant file
and you should never show anyone you'd
end file just calling that out here
cool so nice let's restart
pre-order call 3d secure authentication
Europe is happy oh yeah we actually
didn't implement any success metric
message but now if we go back to our
dashboard we can see the successful
payment were made for our customer Thor
cool
yeah maybe should we do 10 more minutes
for you to glue things together and then
I'm gonna hand over to Paul to give you
a quick look at the payment request API
and using Apple pay in in the browser
and then we're going to wrap things up
at some point cool thanks
yes okay I think we lost a couple people
there that's a bummer because we sort of
kept the coolest thing for the end have
you heard of the payment requests API
who has heard of the payment requests
API call so I think everyone has heard
of the w3c the world wide web consortium
so the governing body of kind of the web
standards and the payment request API is
something that's part of the web
payments working group so there's the
payment request API and the payments
handler API and what it aims at is to
provide a native browser interface to
collect payment details so instead of
everyone having to build their own
checkout page the idea is that the
browser can natively render a UI that is
a native UI to collect payment details
and so if we here look at we can
actually go
into the payment request button
so it's stripe we actually part off the
w3c web payments working group which is
working on this standards to build
native browser payment detail collection
api's whoo and we've wrapped the payment
requests API into an element that you
can use to trigger that UI and securely
collect those Carty sets so for example
here on Chrome we can get a Pay Now
button that will actually trigger the
payment request API maybe let me let me
zoom in there a little so you can see
that and here the payment request API
bundles various different payment
methods or payment vehicles into the
native browser UI and so for example
here via the payment request API I can
access google pay and google pay uses
what is called the payments handler API
to provide via a serviceworker the
Google payment methods into in this
native browser fields so so this is
actually not a pop-up this is a native
chrome UI so here if we select Google
pay and we click on pay this actually
uses the payment handler API so Google
uses the payment handler API to show me
the Google pay our interface natively
within the browser and then I can just
select my stored payment method here and
I can pay with that and the details so
so now the card details that I've stored
in my Google account are securely shared
with with stripe so that the merchants
can actually access those details and
use them for payment now the cool thing
is if we actually open this in the
Safari browser
[Music]
we now get an Apple pay button now the
reason for that is that so Apple does
implement the payment request API Apple
is part of the the web payments working
group as well but they only allow access
to Apple pay as a payment method so
that's why we only get Apple pay here as
a button but we can use Apple pay and I
can then actually access and
unfortunately only on Safari
I can access the car details that are
stored in my Apple account it couldn't
connect to my phone there but I don't
have the fingerprint if I had the new
Mac with the fingerprint sensor I could
actually prove it on on the laptop
otherwise it here it tries to handoff to
my phone so with the payment request
button we can actually access native
wallets and and and sort of native
payment interfaces are here for example
instead of Google pay so on Chrome we
actually have the center we can also
access card details that are saved on my
Chrome so for example these are saved
with autofill my car details and I can I
can access those as well or using Google
pane so that's really nice because on
mobile phones especially if you build a
mobile website it's very convenient you
know to pay with Google Play or Apple
pay and it's cool that you know with
with so the payment request API is part
of the whole progressive web app idea so
it's great that we can build experiences
that actually allow us to to access
native functionality and payment details
that are stored natively on on the
device what you can do so if you wanted
to put this into your application now we
can actually go
dude where is it so here there is a
toggle to implement the payment request
API with payment and tens so we actually
have a callback listener here when what
when we when we access the payment
details on the phone they are shared
directly with stripe stripe then
exchange it it for a token and once we
have the token we fire this callback
handler to tell you that we've got a
payment method
token that you can use and then what you
do is you basically confirm the payment
intent that you created so the payment
intent client secret here again with the
payment method that was shared fired the
payment request API and then we can
react to the results so either it is
successful or we might actually have to
handle authentication so if this uses
Apple pay as a payment method in the
background authentication is actually
handled via the the fingerprint sensor
within the phone but if we for example
via the payment request API if we use
just stored card details that are stored
on the Chrome browser then potentially
we might need to additionally perform
authentication and that's what we do
here with with handler card payment
looking at the time I don't think we
have enough time to actually hook that
into the application if you want to do
that you know feel free to run here
through the payment request QuickStart
you can see it uses it's very similar to
using elements you know with with the
card element but instead what you do you
actually create the payment request with
the details so here you need to provide
the payment details that should be shown
on Apple pay on Google pay so that's why
you put them in here
adjacent object and then we create a
payment request button element here with
our payment request object and we then
can check wired the browser so why are
the payment request API we can check if
we can make a payment so if any of the
native methods or Apple pay Google pay
the payment request API with with stored
card details or even a Microsoft pay is
apparently thing we can check if any of
those methods are available and then if
they are available basically we mount
the payment request button into our form
cool so that's how we can actually get
access to Apple pay on the web why are
the payment requests API the payment
request button any questions on that yes
with you mean was the the hosted
checkout
sorry can you repeat that
[Music]
so the question is if I use the payment
request API within a react native
application does it show the the native
Apple pay behavior I think the answer is
yes Janeway view yes yes
okay yeah so if you want to feel free to
stick around I think the talks continue
again at 4:30 but if you you know if you
want to continue we could we can we're
going to stick around to answer
questions thank you very much for
joining us for this workshop we have
some t-shirts in the back as well as
some issues of increment feel free to
take one there and yeah thank you for
for joining us and if you have any
questions in general about stripe or
stripe in a pack in Singapore feel free
to ask us thanks a lot and enjoy the
rest of James Caan